So the question that I'm posing to you is.
I'm giving you these four page faulting scenarios. And
I want you to fill in the table with
what happens to the boundary between the local and the
global split on each node. And this column is
giving you the location of the faulting page. Where it
is in the entire system. And this column is
saying what happens to the split of L and G
on the faulting node. What happens to the split of L and G on the node that
happens to have the faulting page? And what happens to the split between L and G
for the node that has the globally oldest
page? The LRU page in the entire cluster which
shall be the victim of place replacement, throwing
it out on to the disc. If some page
has to be gotten out of the cluster
because the memory pressure in the entire cluster
exceeds the total memory that's available in the
entire cluster. The first choice is the faulting page
X, is in Q's global cache. That's a first choice. In that case I
want you to think about what happens to the spread of L and G on node P, node Q,
and node R. In the second case, faulting page X is in the
global part of Q. And the difference is, P's global is
already empty. In the first case, P's global was not empty, so I
wanted you to think about the split between L
and G, and note P as well. In the second
case, I'm saying it is similar to the first
one, with a difference that P's global cache is empty.
And the third case is the faulting page is on the disk. It is not in the cluster
memory of any of the nodes. And the last case is when this faulting page X
is actively shared by both P and Q. All of theses cases are the ones that we
just we discussed, and so I just wanted you
to think about it and fill in this table.